et quand vous faites vous quand vous
tombez sur un islamiste radical vous
dites quoi
soit
abdelhakoub bonsoir
alors abdelake vous êtes depuis 2003
aumônier musulman à la prison de
Fleury-Mérogis donc au premier loge pour
observer la radicalisation des musulmans
français en prison et la naissance de
nouveau Mohamed Merah ou Jérémy Louis
Sidney vous dites le radicalisme prison
n'a pas augmenté en nombre en revanche
il a changé de visage du discours il est
passé aux actes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir vous êtes né le 14 octobre 1961
à Casablanca au Maroc père grutier maire
femme au foyer en 1968 vous n'avez pas
encore 7 ans votre père est recruté par
un entrepreneur français pour aller
travailler dans l'Hexagone sur le plan
religieux votre famille n'est pas du
tout impliqué pas de prière seulement le
ramadan par tradition à l'époque
effectivement la religion musulmane
c'était plutôt culturelle qu'autre chose
alors à l'adolescence vous êtes un jeune
homme un peu turbulent vous fumez vous
buvez et vous collectionnez les
aventures amoureuses j'étais un jeune
comme tout le monde
et puis en été vous allez avoir 16 ans
alors que tous les soirs après la
rupture du jeûne du Ramadan vous vous
retrouvez avec vos potes sur un coin de
trottoir aménagé avec des tapis et des
coussins pour jouer aux cartes vous
remarquez que certains se lèvent et s'en
vont souvent sans dire au revoir mais
tout le monde comprenait où ils allaient
ils allaient faire la prière du soir et
puis il revenait bon ça dérangeait
personne et puis ça se faisait sans
aucune ostentation un jour ils s'en vont
tous et là vous leur dites attendez je
viens avec vous et là pour la première
fois de votre vie vous mettez les pieds
dans une mosquée alors à partir de là
vous plongez dans des lectures
théologiques et vous découvrez que tout
ça vous vous passionne vous arrêtez
l'alcool vous arrêtez les cigarettes
vous arrêtez les fleurs sans lendemain
pour vous concentrer sur votre étude
alors autour de vous personne n'y croit
on vous dit pas du tout parce que bon vu
un petit peu ce que j'étais quelques
mois avant est-ce que je suis devenu
quelques mois après c'était c'était un
cont reste un compréhensible si vous
voulez alors en 1980 votre famille
rejoint votre père en France vous vous
venez l'année suivante alors vous faites
deux dogs à Nancy une licence à Bordeaux
et une maîtrise à la Sorbonne pas mal
oui mais bon
j'espère est mieux mais bon voilà c'est
pas mal alors vous deviendrez donc
traducteur correcteur dans une maison
d'édition parallèlement vous vous
impliquez dans le monde associatif
musulman vous commencez à faire des
lectures des conférences et même des
prêches des fois vous remplacez l'imam
oui tout simplement parce qu'il faut
imaginer même aujourd'hui l'islam de
France on parle beaucoup de l'islam de
France mais on ignore que c'est une
coquille vide en quelque sorte au niveau
structurel je veux dire pas en tant que
présence musulmane pas en tant que foi
mais en tant que structuration c'est
vraiment une coquille vide et puis un
jour en 2003 le recteur de la mosquée
d'Evry vous propose de devenir aumô en
prison vous refusez absolument quelques
jours plus tard il vous fait passer une
enveloppe vous attendrez six mois pour
ouvrir cette enveloppe et quand vous
l'ouvrez c'est le choc absolument voyez
des phrases en monsieur Lemonnier
indiquez-moi les heures de prière
monsieur Lemonnier j'ai fait une bêtise
comment me repentir alors là vous êtes
bouleversé par cette lecture vous
regrettez amèrement d'avoir laissé cette
enveloppe dormir pendant 6 mois et vous
êtes prêt à tout laisser tomber pour ça
en fait oui parce que le monde carcéral
c'est un monde que on ne pense jamais et
donc on me propose d'aller en prison
j'ai pas que ça à faire franchement pas
question et puis le choc effectivement
en lisant il y avait presque une dizaine
de courrier des petites phrases mais ces
petites banalités deviennent tellement
importantes pour celui qui est privé de
sa liberté et puis il faut comprendre
aussi la situation des détenus de
confession musulmane dans les prises en
françaises c'est qu'il voyait que leur
code était unique chrétien ou juifs qui
peut recevoir est accueilli par l'aumô
et puis lui il n'a ni aumônier ni faite
n'est rien vous comprenez un petit peu
cette frustration alors vos actions ces
actions de routine a apporté un Coran
apporter un tapis de prière et puis vous
avez aussi des confessions insoutenables
le type qui vous dit J'ai tué ma femme
et mes enfants et après il vous dit pire
je les ai égorgé qu'est-ce qu'on fait
dans ces cas-là alors là en fait vous
vous ne montrez pas votre dégoût parce
que si vous le faisiez cet homme
sombrerait dans le désespoir alors vous
lui dites finalement tu as fait le mal
c'est certain mais essaye de te racheter
dans le restant de ta vie c'est tout ce
que vous pouvez lui dire en fait vous
savez l'homme on est musulman c'est
comme tout autre personne on n'a pas le
droit d'apporter un jugement sur l'autre
mais effectivement intérieurement c'est
un soutenable on n'est pas préparé il
faut le dire on n'est pas psychiatre ni
psychologue ni rien du tout on n'a pas
fait de stage voilà on est plongé dans
ce monde un de l'inconnu et c'est vrai
c'est très dur et puis peu à peu vous
voyez certains détenus plongés dans
l'extrémisme c'est toujours pareil vous
dites c'est le loup dans la bergerie
quoi c'est des types qui sont des
radicaux et qui contaminent les autres
finalement les discours de ces gens-là
c'est un tout ce que tu as fait par le
passé c'est pas grave Dieu te le
pardonnera si tu es musulman 2 tu es en
prison non pas à cause de toi mais parce
que l'État français est islamophobe et
trois les mécréants ne peuvent pas nous
juger seul Dieu peut nous juger alors
évidemment quand vous tombez sur des
mecs comme ça qu'est-ce qu'on fait oui
mais déjà on est choqué si vous voulez
cette conception du pardon c'est quelque
chose qui fait partie de la religion
musulmane comme dans toutes les
religions mais elle n'est pas faite pour
encourager l'individu à continuer à
faire le mal mais pour lui dire bon ce
qui est fait maintenant tu repars à
nouveau donc voilà renforce toi et
essayer de faire isoler cela écoutez ça
ça c'est pas de ressort on pourrait
penser quand même qu'il y ait des
quartiers avec des des radicaux qui ne
puisse pas contaminer les autres ça
serait quand même une mesure de
célébrité publique alors il faut
souligner
tout d'abord que c'est une toute petite
minorité
l'islamiste radicaux en France dans les
prisons c'est rien du tout minorité et
la majorité qui est influencé et le sait
pas il pense que c'est ça la vérité
c'est l'islam qu'on leur présente mais
quand vous faites vous quand vous tombez
sur un islamiste radical vous lui dites
quoi disons que moi j'ai un principe que
je recommande actuellement c'est qu'il
faut toujours laisser l'autre parler il
faut le laisser dire ce qu'il a envie de
dire et c'est après prendre élément par
élément et déconstruire un petit peu sa
pensée pas pour lui parce que c'est très
difficile de les détourner de leur voix
mais pour protéger les autres ils sont
influençables heureusement que vous avez
fait la Sorbonne quand même parce que
pour déconstruire alors vous vous dites
qu'on assiste quand même à la naissance
d'un islamo banditisme alors ils ont une
barbe un calot sur la tête
mais en fait à l'intérieur c'est des
grands délinquants faut comprendre que
ceux qui qui si vous voulez qui qui
glisse vers le radicalisme ce sont des
gens qui n'ont aucune construction
intellectuelle de la religion et non pas
une connaissance approfondie de la foi
mais tout simplement il reproduisent un
petit peu ce qu'il faisait avant
d'entrer en prison avec une coloration
parce qu'on leur a dit c'est pas grave
parce que ce sont pas des musulmans tout
simplement alors une question qui me
brûle l'élève c'est quand il y a Mohamed
Merah par exemple
bon il y a Boubaker qui dit c'est pas
bien mais pourquoi les musulmans ne sont
pas plus nombreux et ne crient-il pas
plus fort leur désaccord les musulmans
depuis une dizaine d'années crit fort
mais personne ne veut les entendre la
quasi-totalité des imams ne cesse de
faire des presses dans ce sens mais on
veut pas nous entendre qu'est-ce que
vous voulez qu'on dise de plus on a des
déclarations on a des articles on a nos
représentant au sein du Conseil français
de culture musulman qui disent la même
chose manifester mais manifester
pourquoi faire pour dire on n'est pas
d'accord moi-même Merah ne peut pas
faire ça ou non au nom de l'islam
l'islam c'est pas ça vous savez la
structuration de l'islam de France n'est
pas aussi forte on part des musulmans de
France on parle de l'islam de France on
parle des représentants mais est-ce que
vous pouvez imaginer une seconde que le
Conseil franc est de culte musulman
fonctionnent avec 0 € de budget il
fonctionne avec des bénévoles comment
voulez-vous que ces représentants que
ces responsables puissent un petit peu
mobiliser aujourd'hui vous savez très
bien faire une manifestation contenait
pas outils et quand il n'est pas bien
organisé quand on n'est pas il y a des
risques de dérapage par contre on est
dans un pays qui est où il y a la
liberté de la parole qu'on nous donne
aussi le le temps les moyens et les
possibilités pour pouvoir nous exprimer
pour ça que vous êtes là je vous en
remercie
alors Samia vous avez dit quelque chose
qui
m'a un peu qui me choque quand vous
dites pourquoi les musulmans ne vont pas
manifester pourquoi lorsqu'il y a un
meurtre un chrétien qui tue qui tue
quelqu'un
au nom de la foi chrétienne qui avait
des gens qui tuaient des gens en disant
je te tue parce que Jésus-Christ m'a
demandé de te tuer je pense que les
évêques on les entendraient en disant la
religion catholique c'est pas ça
qu'ils avaient à dire
reprises effectivement peut-être qu'on
les entend pas beaucoup on leur donne
pas assez la parole la preuve c'est
qu'aujourd'hui quand vous leur donnez la
parole ils sont capables de s'exprimer
et s'exprimer correctement par contre
juste une chose c'est que aussi les
musulmans de France se sentent avant
tout Français et quand il y a quand on
est capable de tuer des enfants quand on
tue quelqu'un il ne le partage pas ils
sont dans la souffrance aussi non mais
c'est important de le dire la majorité
c'est la minorité qui est dans qui est
dans l'extrémisme mais la majorité des
Français qui soient musulmans
pratiquants ou pas pratiquants condamne
croyez-moi au quotidien tout s'est fait
les musulmans sont français et ils sont
touchés comme tout le monde quand ils
regardent la télévision et moi je
propose juste que tous les Français
descendent dans la rue pour manifester
contre ces extrémistes quel qu'il soit
voilà parce que je pense que c'est la
meilleure et des réponses et vous verrez
qu'il y aura beaucoup de jeunes et de
musulmans Français musulmans qui seront
dans la rue aussi pour le dire merci de
votre témoignage et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de Inna larditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu